welcome good afternoon welcome two
reasons first freedom in media event I
want to welcome everyone here in our
Washington office as well as those
watching on recent TV reason.com and
Ustream
I am Stephen touch I am moderator and
I'm telecom and new media analyst for
the reason foundation we've titled
today's presentation beyond the seven
dirty words protecting the internet and
new media from content regulation this
of course is a reference the seven dirty
words that the standards and practices
said couldn't be said on TV at least
until TV ratings came along and although
content standards have become more
flexible there still remains among
legislators and regulators a temptation
to censor content techniques are a
little more subtle nobody really goes
after direct political or or our
artistic expression we hear terms like
cultural sensitivity decency taste we
hear things like well a blogger isn't a
real journalist so therefore we need
different regulations you know but it's
it's always been an easy target to go
after new media new technologies whether
it was rock and roll or jazz or comic
books or television back in the day but
it's really sometimes just disappointing
to see some political leaders who should
know better going this route we had the
innocence of Muslims it was not a very
tasteful video nonetheless the Obama
administration felt necessary to blame
the embassy the consulate attack in
Benghazi on an Internet video we we hear
we hear about video games being invited
to be part of a dialogue on gun control
bottom line the First Amendment declares
that government has no role in
regulating or curtailing speech or
expression and the courts have made that
clear that extends to electronic media
what's more because of the way the
internet works it offers far more
opportunities for individuals to
participate in the so-called marketplace
of ideas so just we'll be looking at
both those aspects today but to start
things off I'd like to introduce our
keynote speaker Robert Korn Revere
partner in Davis Trey Davis right
Tremaine mr. Korn Revere has argued and
won several high-profile First Amendment
cases his clients have ranged from major
TV networks to the comic book Legal
Defense Fund
mr. Cohen Revere represented CBS in a
successful challenge to the FCC's
indecency finding and 550,000 dollar
penalty over that famous Janet Jackson
wardrobe malfunction during the 2004
Superbowl halftime show mr. Corin Revere
also represented CBS and a consolidated
appeal challenging the FCC's application
of broadcast indecency rules to
so-called fleeting expletives and brief
nudity from that show that's that some
of you might remember NYPD Blue that
case was only resolved last year and the
US Supreme Court held that the FCC's
decisions targeting these fleeting
indecencies is unconstitutional so
indeed mr. country's legal acumen has
been instrumental in beating back
numerous government attempts to regulate
or censor free speech and to determine
what Americans see hear or read he has
shown the courts that laws such as the
Communications Decency Act online child
protection act and restrictions on the
sale and rental of video games however
well-intentioned they might be do not
pass First Amendment tests so it's my
pleasure to give you a great friend of
Reason and a true hero in the battle for
free speech Robert Kahn Revere
thanks to you did you want me up here or
okay well I appreciate being here I
always appreciate coming to Reason
events always talking about freedom and
and timely topics and there's really
nothing more timely than the interaction
between the First Amendment and new
communications technologies and because
it's timely I thought I should start
with a news item as reported in
Scientific American July 6 1901 an
instance of the in capable and
inexplicable conservatism and arrogance
of the Turkish customs authorities was
recently evidenced by the prohibition of
the importation of typewriters into the
country
the reason advanced by the authorities
for this step is that typewriting
affords no clue to the author and that
therefore in the event of seditious or
opprobrious pamphlets or writings
executed by the typewriter being
circulated it would be impossible to
obtain any clue by which the operator of
the machine could be traced the same
decree also applies to the mimeograph
and other similar duplicating machines
and mediums okay 1901 it's official and
the oldest guy in the room
this has always been a perennial topic I
mentioned that not to make fun of
repressive middle-eastern governments
like almost like a redundancy and and
particularly when you think of the Arab
Spring and the notion of the governments
of Egypt and Syria Tunisia turning off
the internet because people were
organizing useful using social media it
seems like this would be just a an
antiquated application of the same
phenomenon but this isn't just something
that pertains to that region of the
world it is part of the endless cycle of
the tension between new technologies and
authoritarian responses of trying to
limit the power that they bring the
power that they bring to the individual
as a matter of fact there there's a real
irony here in that technologies while
they expand human freedom have always
led to efforts to repress them I've
written in the past that censorship is
the bastard child of technology and in
many ways we've seen that cycle repeat
itself many times over in history for
example if you think of the advent of
movable-type and the Gutenberg press in
1450 there really weren't any organized
attempts no institutions of censorship
before that time of course there didn't
need to be because scribes were produced
one by one and they were they they
produced books singularly and they were
under the control of the hierarchy of
the church and you didn't need any kind
of organized censorship Bureau it was
only once you had the ability to
mass-produce books that you began to see
efforts in Europe and in England to then
begin to restrict the availability of
the Free Press and we saw this actually
instituted through various mechanisms
there was the court of the Star Chamber
instituted by Henry the eighth
for example which wasn't instituted
specifically to suppress the press and
as a matter of fact it had some laudable
aspirations for why the court of the
Star Chamber was created it was created
because Nobles and prominent people
could escape justice in the regular
civil courts and so you needed some
court that was under the control of the
king that could then impose sanctions on
people of higher status the problem was
it quickly became a method of
suppression of any dissenters against
the king and particularly during the
Reformation which had been made possible
through the mass dissemination of books
you then saw religious dissenters become
the target of the court of the Star
Chamber as a matter of fact there was a
decree and I think 1632 prohibiting the
publication of news books because
diplomats from Austria and I think Spain
had complained that coverage in these
books of the 30 Years War was unfair I
suppose you could call it the first
example of the Fairness Doctrine but
that was again the court of the Star
Chamber we saw that eventually fade away
but it was replaced by England's
licensing law which required all
publishers to be registered all authors
all printers also to be registered and
that gave the stationers company a
monopoly over the press with the ability
to do search and seizure of publications
that were considered to be offensive to
the crown and basically to exert control
now again the licensing law was the
function of Parliament and it wasn't
that Parliament in finally phasing out
the the court of the Star Chamber was in
favour of press freedom it's just that
they preferred to exert control as
opposed to directly control from the
king but eventually all of these events
and all of these efforts of control
began to fade away and yet they were
prominent in the minds of the framers of
the United States Constitution when that
document was being written in the Bill
of Rights was being formed it was also
prominent during the trial of John Peter
Zenger
in 1735 which addressed the issue of
seditious libel all of those things led
to the creation of the First Amendment
there are foremost in the minds of the
framers and they adopted an amendment
that Congress shall make no law
respecting the establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of people to
peaceably assemble or to petition the
government for redress of grievances
those 45 words were adopted because the
framers of the United States
Constitution adopted this new
communications technology the one mass
disability to mass disseminated works at
the time as an integral part of the
United States Constitution and an
integral part of our political freedoms
now you would think that's the end of
history right
you have framers of the Constitution
they adopted a provision is designed to
make sure that government doesn't have
control over the ability to mass-produce
works of expression and that should be
the end of it
well sadly it's not because
constitutional freedoms are not
self-enforcing it does require the
courts to interpret and to ultimately
enforce those rights and the First
Amendment really wasn't interpreted
applied by the courts until after the
first quarter of the 20th century it's
only then that the Supreme Court began
to look at some of these issues and to
gradually begin defining and expanding
freedoms under the First Amendment the
problem was that when it came to issues
of Technology the courts were very
reluctant to say that those hard-fought
freedoms also applied to new
technologies we saw this cycle repeat
itself on many different occasions for
example it repeated itself with the
issue of cinema in 1915 the Supreme
Court first addressed whether or not
film was protected by the First
Amendment and the answer came back well
of course not
state Commission's were growing up to
provide advanced censorship of films and
the court said that this is not a
function of the press this is merely an
entertainment its commerce and by the
way we think films are a little
dangerous you really shouldn't show
pictures to everybody because it might
give them the wrong ideas
it took another 37 years before the
Supreme Court again addressed the issue
of cinema and found that yes in fact
this technology was fully protected by
the First Amendment but it's again an
issue that we confront again and again
and yet we don't seem to learn the
lesson that having been through that
with one technology we should extend the
same protections to all we're still
fighting those issues when it comes to
broadcasting because broadcasters are
licensed under the Communications Act of
1934 which when you think about it is
really pretty ironic because the First
Amendment was a product of men who were
rebelling against the very concept of
press licensing that was the history in
England that was in their minds when
they adopted the First Amendment and so
when we have this newer technology come
along the answer according to Congress
when it adopted the law was well why
don't we license broadcasters now
wouldn't you think that obvious that
that at least creates some tension with
the First Amendment which says Congress
shall make no law abridging freedom of
speech or the press we might think so
but again we've had to fight these
battles each time the court has to
reinterpret what the First Amendment
means in the face of a new means of
communication
matter of fact William Howard Taft who
was both President and the later Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court when he was
on the court said he wanted to put off
for as long as possible the issue of
what First Amendment rights apply to
broadcasters because he consider radio
akin to the occult and so they managed
to prevent that issue from actually
being resolved for the longest time and
it's still not resolved the first time
the course dealt with it was in the
early 1930s in 1932 the then federal
radio Commission the predecessor to the
FCC had revoked the license of a radio
station for an inflammatory radio
preacher
imagine that and when a First Amendment
challenge was brought the circuit court
reached essentially the same conclusion
that the Supreme Court had with respect
to films saying that this is an
instrument of Commerce and we don't
think that the First Amendment prevents
the FCC from revoking a broadcast
license they finally went to the Supreme
Court in the 40s in the NBC case looking
at the constitutionality of what we'll
call chain broadcasting rules or network
rules and that's where the court first
began to apply the notion of frequency
scarcity as a justification for treating
broadcasting differently came back to
the Supreme Court in 1969 in the Red
Lion case which upheld the Fairness
Doctrine and then last year there was a
test of the FCC's broadcast indecency
rules in which case the court reached
the right conclusion that the attempt to
enforce the rules was unconstitutional
as a violation of due process but it
stops short of reaching the ultimate
First Amendment question of whether or
not broadcasting should apply should
have applied to it the same
constitutional standard as other media
again the pattern repeats with every new
technology we saw it with cable
television for example which the FCC
initially decided it was going to treat
simply as broadcasting even though cable
didn't rely on the electro Mattox
electromagnetic spectrum in the same way
as broadcasters which is how you
justified this different level of
regulation and so beginning in probably
the 70s
when the FCC first wrote its cable
television rules until the 90s when some
of these concepts would be began to be
tested the court stopped short of trying
to reach what level of First Amendment
protection should apply to cable even
though it acknowledged in some of these
cases that maybe the rules are a little
different for this medium finally in the
year 2000 in a case that I argued the
United States versus Playboy
Entertainment Group the court reached
the conclusion that no the same standard
that applies to broadcasting does not
apply to cable television and as a
result it was going to apply
a more robust first amendment standard
even though some vestiges of that
regulatory history continue even in the
cable medium finally with the internet
we see a genuine breakthrough and this
is true on a couple of levels the
Internet is interesting for so many
reasons
it has transformed the world but in the
regulatory world it's interesting
because it caught the government
unawares it came along the Internet even
though it had its origins in some
government research the world wide web
was developed not as a result of any
kind of government program but it was
there and then the government had to
later figure out what it was going to do
with it including to try and figure out
what constitutional standard applied
well what would you imagine would be the
first impulse of government to a
technology of this kind of power and
magnitude anybody of course it's to
regulate it and and of course the
regulatory structure that was adopted in
the Telecommunications Act of 1996 or at
least a portion of that act called the
Communications Decency Act was to impose
broadcast style indecency regulations on
the internet so that regime involving
the seven dirty words this tea was
talking about that was going to be
applied to the Internet now for anybody
who uses the Internet and that would be
Oh everybody it's hard to even imagine
what that world would look like if it
were subject to the kind of FCC
regulations that still today apply to
broadcasting but that case did
ultimately go to the Supreme Court and
in 1997 the court ruled that there is no
justification for treating the internet
with any different level of first
mention than you would for traditional
media that was a staggering astounding
conclusion it is the first time in our
history that and it's the first court
test of a new technology the court held
that full First Amendment protections
apply
and for that reason it's really
remarkable but there are other reasons
as well I mean for example as I
mentioned the internet sort of developed
in the absence of a government program
rather than because of a government
program can you even imagine what this
technology would look like if it had
been the product of an FCC notice and
comment rulemaking proceeding well we
wouldn't have to imagine it because we
wouldn't have an internet yet we would
still be waiting for the internet
because any proceeding of that kind
would take years it would take decades
to to produce any kind of result and
when it did do you think we would have
the kind of free speech that we have on
the internet today well no we would have
a set of rules that look like the New
York telephone directory and well
actually do they still publish that
there are there still telephone
directories I guess there are but nobody
really uses them as much anymore because
we have these great new technologies
that democratize information and make
information universally available
because of that we have achieved through
the absence of government regulation
more in the nature of Public Interest
benefits than were ever produced by
decades of regulation applied to other
electronic media I was at an event
probably 20 years ago where someone was
talking about the benefits of cable
television regulations including the
regulations that require local cable
operators to provide public access
channels so that individuals would have
the ability to speak to their community
through these channels that are set
aside for public speech and he said you
know probably the best show I ever saw
was on a public access channel and I
doubt if anyone else really wanted to
watch it but they were covering on that
channel my daughter's ballet recital and
so what we people had a chance to see it
on TV and I turned to her I said
so I guess this happened before the
advent of camcorders right I mean even
then if someone wanted to watch their
daughter's ballet recital on television
they could do a camcorder you didn't
need this regulatory apparatus to
regulate the entire community and to
basically confiscate channels for
private use or in this case public use
but with a private audience of one so
that you could achieve this result those
regulations are still in place and still
put a dragon on cable operators around
the nation in their areas of franchise
and yet with the internet we have
through YouTube through any number of
channels the ability to speak to a
global audience without the need for
this kind of regulatory apparatus once
again by the absence of government
oversight we have seen the development
of Public Interest benefits that
couldn't have been imagined by
government regulators the the problem
that we face going forward is that the
lessons that seen it are seemingly
obvious and in front of us every day are
really lost whenever we confront a new
problem that is the next time we see an
issue come up involving the Internet
will we instinctively or will
policymakers instinctively think well we
gained all these benefits through not
applying regulation in the past maybe we
should do that going forward the problem
is when new problem when new issues come
along quite often the initial impulse is
to find a way for a mandatory solution
to try and solve the problem for
everybody we see this time and time
again with various internet issues for
example there's the issue of Internet
governance
I used the word governance because it
does imply a regulatory solution
and in the 90s when the Supreme Court
decided the reno case which held that
the internet was fully protected by the
First Amendment the administration at
the time the Clinton administration was
fully aware that if you tried to impose
a governmental solution after it hadn't
lost the the reno case that you might
lose the benefits of the of the internet
and so when it came to issues of
managing domain names for example they
proposed having a private solution and i
can in managing domain names that
solution is still in place today
imperfect as it is but it is there but
because there are problems that come up
with ICANN you have people calling for
not internet management or domain name
management but internet governance that
is having governmental institutions
through a treaty through something like
the UN impose regulations over the
internet it's a truly frightening
prospect we see this issue come up with
other technologies not just internet
technologies as well
Pete Tucker is here and he'll be
speaking to you from the panel and the
first time I met Pete he had just gotten
out of jail he'll probably tell you a
little bit more about that but because
he had had the temerity to take a
photograph at a public meeting now in
any setting where you have protections
for the press that's truly frightening
but because technologies that has
extended the ability of every individual
to be carrying a camera and not just a
camera but a video recorder with them at
pretty much all times
if that technology is not respected and
protected by the constitutional
protections and by government policies
then you stand the risk of turning every
individual into a criminal we're still
looking at whether or not this
technology is going to be protected by
the courts and so far the decisions that
we've seen have been very promising but
again as each new development occurs we
have to fight that battle over and over
again we see this as well with the
ability to carry all of your personal
life on a laptop computer or
a pad when you travel around but yet one
of the implications of that is that when
you cross an international border the
Fourth Amendment protection against
search and seizure doesn't really apply
and that is if border agents want to
open your computer look through the
files they can do so and decisions up to
this point if said they don't even have
to have reasonable suspicion to be able
to do that let alone a search warrant
now again courts in the Ninth Circuit
just last week issued an opinion that
that suggested that there is a growing
sensitivity to these issues that
technology bring but as I've said before
it is a lesson that we need to learn
over and over again so I'm hoping that
events like this will help sensitize you
all to these issues and bring insights
and talk about some of the issues that
are coming up and hopefully as we move
forward these lessons ultimately will
sink in thank you thank you excuse me
thank you Bob I'm not sure if our we
have Pete Tucker is going to join us
now and I'd like to invite Bob to to
participate as well we are we are
expected to have a second panelist who
is not here yet Chuck Chuck Stewart from
smack time entertainment but let me
introduce Pete Tucker you already got a
brief introduction from Bob Pete Tucker
is the founder and publisher of the
fightback dot org this is an online
publication that covers policy in
Washington DC from more or less the
street level it looks at to how
rulemakings policy makings laws affect
poor disenfranchised people trying to
simply get by and as Bob said last year
Pete was covering a public meeting of
the Washington DC taxi Commission he was
photographing he was along side a reason
reporter in New York based Reason
reporter Jim
you the chairman of the Commission asked
them both to stop photographing and
recording they did not and they were
arrested mr. corn Revere helped us out
much on that so I'd like to invite Pete
to come up to talk about some of his
experiences as an online journalist and
an online publisher Bob if you'd care to
join us on stage I'd like to start with
with with Pete maybe starting really to
address some of the public interest side
of what the internet now creates that
that bob was mentioning what are you
what what have you been able to do
through the fight back that would not
have been possible se5 as little as five
years ago thank you so much for the
introduction good afternoon and thank
you to reason and for including me and
let me say what a privilege it is to
participate in discussion that
highlights popcorn Revere I actually
knew of his work before I met him as was
mentioned I was arrested
that was actually National Park Police
Headquarters the taxicab Commission was
holding its meeting after several hours
in jail I was being led out and I think
I think I think Bob had showed up he was
representing Jim Epstein that the reason
reporter who was arrested for filming my
arrest and I was getting back my shoes
and my belt they take that so you don't
kill yourself it what I was upset by
wasn't that upset and so as I'm getting
this stuff back the the officer she's
handing back my phone to and that some
head guy walks in and he says all the
phones go back and so she reached to
take my phone back he said no no no no
no they go and I think was at that point
that Bobbitt showed up I'm guessing the
timing cuz they're just to have a high
up person come in and make it you know a
quick abrupt decision and you let him
know about the First Amendment
and not only did I get my phone back but
the other reporter who had the whole
thing on video got his phone back and
the difference that that made was that
upon arrest the taxicab Commission put
out that I was disruptive and all this
stuff and when the video went out it
just put all that it just put all that
to shame so for that and many other
reasons it's a privilege to get to have
a discussion with Bob and yeah the
Internet is as everyone here knows it is
an amazing tool and as bob was pointed
out it's not the first time in American
history that we have a new media with
which to reach out to people and every
time that happens there is a push to
clamp down on it it is you know one of
the scary things right now I think in
addition to some of the concerns
concerns that Bob raised is you these
are some of the largest corporations on
earth that are looking to to do what
they've done historically in this
country which is you have periods of
openings whether it be the newspaper
which was part of the reason that this
country fomented a successful revolution
and one of the reasons why that first
amendment is enshrined the way it is and
from the radio to the television and now
the internet any time these new openings
come in there is a chance for
individuals and small groups of people
to reach large numbers of people and
then it seemed to clamp down pretty
quickly there's an amazing book out
recently called news for all the people
banach Juan Gonzalez and Joe Torres Juan
Gonzalez co-host of Democracy Now and
Joe Torre's is with Free Press and it
documents how first of all how excluded
minorities are in the history of this
country when it comes to the media but
also how these openings are short lived
and this ability right now to reach
large numbers of people that I think
probably looking at the age of us here
in this room we all take for granted
is nothing to be taken for granted at
all if you look at u.s. history and the
attacks whether it be sista the big
companies uh-huh and as well as the
government it is going to take a serious
fight as it did a year ago with sista to
protect this privilege to reach people
which we all take for granted and yeah
it has you know you through the website
and Twitter and Facebook you're able to
bring the voices of the street to large
numbers of people which is an incredible
privilege and opportunity and one that I
think we all need to do a lot to protect
well let's both of you what what do you
see is really the the greatest threats
right now are the things that worry you
again there doesn't seem to be that much
of a direct attempt to say let's let's
regulate web sites but we we see
attempts to regulate comments to hold
website publishers liable for what might
be posted on their site or third party
deputize ation you've got to report
something those are some examples there
might be others but what what are some
of the the regulatory proposals that
don't sound like censorship yet the net
result may be suppression of content
the danger is that there's always a good
reason to regulate regulation isn't
proposed by people bent on some evil
plan of control well sometimes it is but
usually not I mean usually there's there
regulation is proposed for very good
insufficient reasons even if you go back
to broadcast regulations and talk about
the Fairness Doctrine the notion behind
it was that it was just meant to codify
good journalistic practice which I'm all
for a good journalistic practice but
when it's done by government mandate not
such a good idea and so you'll see all
kinds of regulations being proposed that
have useful and beneficial purposes but
that are ultimately either unworkable or
had some flaw in the design in the first
place take for example network
neutrality which is a principle actually
that term is such a nice PR term it's
hard to know exactly what it means it
kind of means many things to many
different people but the notion behind
it is the network should be free and
open to all and so we should regulate in
the name of making sure it's free and
open to all the difficulty with doing
that is that you have to define terms
you need to decide who's going to be in
control of the network and when you have
dispersal of that that the ability to
control even when it's to major
corporations that at least isn't
centralizing it in one Authority that's
going to make one rule one size fits all
and that's one of the difficulties I
testified at a an FCC hearing on this
once and I found it necessary to remind
people at the hearing that you have to
look at the history of government
efforts to regulate in this area where
of course the first impulse is to
regulate content but even if you look at
efforts of the FCC to create regulations
to design open networks and they've been
through this various times with a
proposal around the turn of the century
called video dial tone
the turn of the last century not 1900
again or open video systems which were
designed as part of the
Telecommunications Act of 1996 they were
all spectacular failures they were
regulations in search of a market rather
than a market that had developed out
there that needed some sort of
regulatory touches you see this as well
with issues involving to the domain name
system or take for example Senator
Lieberman's proposal for an internet
kill switch right because of course
China had one so we should have one too
and you know what as I say there are
always good and sufficient reasons to
regulate I mean that was being proposed
in the name of cybersecurity and
particularly in light of news events now
who could be against cybersecurity but
you have to be careful about once you
open the door what walks through and and
usually I've found that with these kinds
of technologies once you open the door
to some kind of government control that
the next thing that follows isn't so
beneficial and helpful and I would just
add to that that I think the well first
of all the Internet is amazing tool but
it already has cut off so many people I
mean the cost of our phones is such that
a large part of this country finds it
first of all a lot of people can't even
get broadband in this country even if
they wanted to but a professor I was in
a met a professor from Kansas he's
originally from South Korea and he would
take some students from South Korea and
they would come to I think was the
University of Pittsburg in Kansas Lee
thought maybe they're coming to an
eastern US city and they would come to
and South Korea's got amazing broadband
so they would come to the middle of
Kansas and they would say South Korea is
more America than Kansas is so people
are caught off that way and then people
are cut off because it's just expensive
to pay these monthly bills cuts off a
lot of people as it is and a fear that I
have going forward is that well with
network neutrality
the fight back without resources loads
at the same speed as NBC but when well
yes I think it is concerning that you
don't want you know the government and
it can do overreach when it comes to
things and controlling but the same is
true with some of the largest
corporations on earth and if they
control the landscape and they can
charge one rate for your website to load
it a good speed and it for those of
people don't have enough money you get
it lowered at a slower rate essentially
you're again cutting off a lot of people
and so I think that is a very serious
concern and that then that follows the
pattern of what's happened in this
country new media comes along and the
big boys come in and so I find that to
be an additional concern who gets access
already as I said a lot of people are
cut off and then if you have a
two-tiered system within that I think
that is a potential to cut off a lot
more but let me pursue that a little bit
on at your level do you I do you and and
have trouble being recognized as a
legitimate journalists as as as a
counterpart at the Washington Post of
the times or even one of the community
newspapers that are usually weekly or
bi-weekly obviously there was a trouble
at the DC Commission understanding that
is that changing or is that is that an
issue and is and and it's part of that
is there a difference between a blogger
and an online journalist it was very
when I was arrest that I was interested
to see how the media covered it I was
fortunate they said reporters The
Washington Post editorial said to
reporters were arrested and it could
have gone either way so I was very
appreciative because that's how I view
myself and I think it's very important
to be accurate you know you want to
strive to be to be accurate and I do and
then
beyond that I mean the difference we
know bloggers and online journalism you
just try and be accurate as best you can
if you make a mistake you know you you
you live up to that and you note it but
yeah you just try and put yourself out
there and since I'm covering activism
I'm usually going to where other
reporters are not so you don't have to
really convince someone who's out
protesting and no other media is paying
attention look I really am a reporter I
swear you got a microphone they'll talk
people want to get their message out
many people are silenced by a corporate
media that is it doesn't have enough
reporters on the street and that's why I
became reported because as an activist I
saw time and again that issues that I
was working on and that others were
working on did not have access to the
media and when you did it was fleeting
if you did if you did it was very
fleeting and dismissive
there are people there angry okay on to
the weather and that's not enough you
get the soundbite but you don't get the
whole meal and so you don't have to
convince people out protesting you know
I swear I'm a journalist you know
they'll talk I'm thinking more in
official circles like when you go for
that calm after you've talked to the
people on the street you go for that
comment at the at the official level or
at the governing level mostly I'm in DC
and DC folks know me I suppose that that
will definitely if I tried to go to the
hill and cover stuff there that would be
an ongoing issue that I have to wrestle
with I was just gonna say this is one of
the issues that we confront in the law
because of changes in technology because
everybody has the tools available that
they can potentially speak to a global
audience or even a microscopic regional
audience to the extending on how the
message is targeted and because of that
it has put some significant tensions on
the way in which officials deal with
people are they journalists are they
members of the press are they just
somebody out there with a gripe and it
may affect how they treat them and
because of that there is quite a bit of
uncertainty
you know the
question do bloggers qualify as
journalists well if they're proof
they're performing journalism that of
course yes but it's kind of like the the
old Smothers Brothers song by the
streets of Laredo where the line is you
can tell by my outfit that I'm a cowboy
if you get an outfit you can be a cowboy
too well just because you've got a
reporter's pad or a microphone doesn't
make you a reporter doesn't make you a
journalist but the First Amendment
protects you nonetheless you have the
same protections under the First
Amendment whether or not you are
officially recognized as a journalist
and this we see come up in various ways
one is getting press credentials right I
mean different cities will credential
people as reporters but they have to go
through a process for that and whether
or not they recognize them can make the
difference on whether or not they get to
go on the other side of police lines and
then you see the issue come up in the
very kinds of cases in which Pete was
caught up in the arrest of people who
are reporting or taking photographs and
because everyone has the technology with
them now pretty much at all times the
question has come up in these cases
whether or not individuals who are not
members of the press have the same First
Amendment protections and fortunately so
far the courts have reached the uniform
conclusion they can have the same level
of first impression when you're out
there taking photographs of people doing
their official duties whether or not
you're officially recognized as a member
of the press or not and yet the
questions keep coming back in different
forms there was a decision in the
Virginia Supreme Court just last week on
whether or not a an attorney could be
sanctioned for his blogging activities
and it was considered the Supreme Court
of the state said yes it could be
because it was a blog and therefore this
was commercial speech because even
though he was reporting on legal matters
the blog was connected to his law firm
website and therefore that made it
commercial even though his activities
were then talking about legal
developments generally as well as on the
cases that he wrote on so again these
questions are going to recur in various
different forms
and it's it's particularly significant
that we keep reminding courts that the
First Amendment should apply regardless
of the way in which you perform your
expressive acts do we have questions
from the audience at this point done
okay well take the I'll take question
from the audience and then go from
Twitter the question was if you could
address where intellectual property laws
intersect here where do they intersect
everywhere I mean the the Internet is a
huge copying machine right and so manok
the ability to use another person's
intellectual property is seeming
seemingly endless that has led to
legislative reactions for whether or not
websites can be responsible because they
happen to post information that someone
a third party has posted on them and so
the Digital Millennium Copyright Act
provides a whole notice and takedown
regime for what the third party website
is supposed to do to avoid getting in
trouble themselves for assisting in
copyright infringement there's the whole
question of trademark and what to do
about domain names and again I can is in
the process of permitting sort of a dot
anything regime where you can have sort
of for all those people who applied for
these things sort of an endless number
of top-level domains now the difficulty
there for trademark holders of course is
that someone may want to capitalize on
your popular and and well-established
trademark and so as a result they'll
create a website using you know X on dot
whatever right and and so that is a
matter that's very concerning to
trademark holders and so we have to find
ways of trying to balance these rights
and to do it in a way that doesn't go
completely overboard which actually gets
back to one of your earlier questions
about what do you do about
third-party intermediaries the people
who simply allow stuff to be posted even
though they aren't responsible for
either infringing someone's copyright or
posting something that's defamatory or
something else here's where the US
Congress actually blundered into one of
the best internet laws ever and that's
section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act which was adopted largely in
part on purpose and in part by accident
and it happened when the legislation
that became the Communications Decency
Act was being debated in 1995 and some
people thought that the proposal of this
heavy-handed FCC style regulation went
too far and so then representative Cox
said well why don't we do something else
will adopt this Good Samaritan provision
that says that internet intermediaries
will not be held responsible for the
content that other people post but
they'll also have the ability to take
stuff down
if they consider it to be offensive or
infringing or something like that and so
that was the origin of the law that
doesn't hold say Google responsible for
the fact that someone may find
infringing material when they do a
search because they were just the
intermediary that allow someone to find
it they didn't post it themselves that
has done as much or more to expand
internet freedom as anything else and
yet it was something that was adopted
really
not exactly accidentally but that wasn't
the intent when it was adopted Congress
of course being Congress said looked at
these two different proposals and said
what the hell let's adopt both and so
that was that was how that came about I
don't have anything to add to that I do
want to get in the queue I have a
question for Bob as well
this one is from the bridge Zack on
Twitter his question is what would be a
better way than net neutrality to
address concerns about ISPs restricting
data transmission and a reminder you can
ask questions on Twitter hashtag freedom
and media or on Facebook or reason com
well frankly I think competition is the
best way to deal with that I mean the
fact that if there are internet
companies that adopt restrictive
policies there is more ability to open
alternatives in the online environment
than there ever had been in the history
of electronic media and I actually had
this conversation with someone last week
where they were lamenting the fact that
they thought Facebook policies were too
restrictive of an idea that they had to
promote sexual freedom now I'm all in
favor of sexual freedom
I like sexual freedom but whether or not
you can force Facebook to change their
editorial policies because you think
that they are somehow a public Town
Square is really in other questions so
again I think the regulatory solution to
try to adopt federal oversight of
networks is really a mistake that
actually feeds into the question I want
to get Bob's thoughts on which is this
sista you I'm trying to read up on it
and I think you know an awful lot more
about it but part of it is you have a
lot of data being gathered from
consumers is a major part of it spoken
to there let me just offer my comments
and then if you can comment on that I
think that it's critically important
that we do have network neutrality
because I think that functionally
there's only I mean how do I know
you know what company your phone is you
know you know you there's just very few
companies that we have to go through and
so I
think their due needs to be a basic set
of rules otherwise we're gonna
unfunctional e we have already have the
the infrastructure this country is 80
Verizon you know t-mobile basically if
we covered it sprint so it's not like
there is theoretically what was that the
but probably the ones we just named
probably ninety percent of the country
and so theoretically a start-up can come
in but practically that's that's not the
case so I would say to the to the the
question on Twitter that you know net
neutrality to me would probably be the
web best way but as I said I've been
trying to read up on sista and I was
wondering your thoughts on it and the
concerns you have telecoms that have
worked with the government and the huge
amounts of our personal data being
stored in a few concerns about that and
you could explain it to cuz I don't
claim to be an expert expert on either
this is the the current proposal to
address cyber cyber security issues at
the heart of it would allow us security
agencies access to information that is
collected by major carriers to address
cyber security concerns again very
controversial and I think that these
kinds of regulations always have the
danger of going too far in allowing
access to that kind of information just
as you know when you look at previous
efforts over the last major rewrite of
our electronic surveillance laws the
Electronic Communications Privacy Act of
1986 was again an effort to strike the
same kind of balance for what network
carriers what kind of information they
had to provide or what kind of process
the government had to go through before
it could get access to information and
install wiretaps and things like that
I guess Kalia which the communications I
can't remember what the acronym stands
for but law enforcement Assistance Act
which was adopted in the mid 90s which
was designed as Network started becoming
digital to require them to provide some
measure of ability for the government to
continue to conduct warranted or when it
was authorized electronic surveillance
despite the fact that the technology had
changed but anytime we go through these
changes in the law to keep up with
technology you have to be particularly
vigilant that Congress doesn't go too
far in allowing the government access to
too much private information because
obviously when you're doing business
with a company or with anybody they're
going to have information and sometimes
that information they're stored on their
systems that is confidential and should
be protected I'll take a question in the
back I just I appreciate becoming it
you're speaking you're saying you're on
the Lions Den talking about net
neutrality and I appreciate your defense
of it I'd like to keep the discussion
more on the internet content regulation
I realize net neutrality has a dimension
of that but I think more or less our
panel will be more in agreement as we
say one thing about that because people
talk about Internet freedom and network
neutrality and content regulation all
sort of in the same vein but network
neutrality is not designed really to to
protect Internet content I mean some
people will try and frame it at that but
proponents of network neutrality have a
very difficult time coming up with
examples of people actually restricting
content they're really more concerned
about bandwidth controls and they're
it's a question of whether or not the
the builders and the companies that run
networks have the ability to do
bandwidth management to determine
whether or not the network can be used
by all the all the users and one way of
regulating that is by price and
and you know other bye-bye corporate
policies that they adopt so the debate
over network neutrality really focuses
on that but even though that's the focus
it will sometimes be justified as saying
that these companies are going to censor
us and that's really not the issue
this is a question our questionnaire is
a DJ noting that DJ's often mix two
songs together doing so without
permission of a copyright holders is the
question is is is this is this a
copyright issue because it does involve
the creation of something new right yeah
and and you know obviously it's a
copyright issue where you're taking the
intellectual property that belongs to
one person and then creating some sort
of new new expression new commercialized
product but it's one that the courts
have dealt with really over time first
it to preface this I'm not an
intellectual property expert and also I
have no idea what the practice of most
DJ's might be again all this guy in the
room but that being said the Supreme
Court has addressed this for example in
the 90s in the 2 Live Crew case where 2
Live Crew had a parody of the song
pretty woman and the question was
whether or not this was an infringement
and there the court looked at the use
and saw that it was a transformative use
of this existing intellectual property
that is what they borrowed from the
original work was enough so that they
could create something new and the
question is again how much are you
really just copying and using and
profiting from somebody else's work and
how much are you creating something new
I remember 2 Live Crew yes this one is
from Facebook
Brad Hobbs asks could you guys touch on
the impact of the newly passed law and
Great Britain requiring public publisher
registration as the internet is
available in the UK what will be the
impact with Britain's loosey-goosey
libel shopping laws
if I were as loaded as that question I'd
be ashamed to be here III really can't
speak to the the law in Great Britain
and I would be interested in hearing
more about that generally the law in
Britain is much more favorable to libel
plaintiffs that if you are sued for
libel you have to then demonstrate that
what you wrote was true as opposed to
presumption in this country that says
that if you are depending on the nature
of the libel plaintiff whether it's a
public official a public figure a
private citizen they still have the
burden of proof to show that what you
wrote was false and knowingly false with
differing levels of of protection and
different different presumptions with
respect to this question about
registering publishers this is an issue
that has become controversial because of
the new technologies and one that again
goes back to the early British licensing
laws where you had to register the
publisher identify the author identify
the the printer all of those things and
those were the kinds of issues that were
foremost in the minds of the framers of
the Constitution it's one of the reasons
why the Federalist Papers were written
under pseudonyms because the framers of
the Constitution that people who devised
the system these geniuses who devised a
system that can be run by idiots decided
that you needed to have those kinds of
protections even for anonymous speech
and as a result court decisions over the
last 50 years have recognized that in
the United States you do have a right to
speak anonymously but as new
technologies come along and as people
get upset that you'll have anonymous
bloggers you'll have people posting
comments scurrilous horrible things
about people online and they'll do it
without attribution they'll do it
without identifying themselves that we
need a new law but the fact is the
reasons that gave birth to the First
Amendment
and that led to the court decisions with
previous technologies about anonymous
speech apply equally to online speech
and the dangers of requiring people to
identify themselves either as publishers
or its posters of comments those
impulses are extremely damaging to I
think our traditions of free expression
I faced this issue in the late 90s when
I would help with a case involving
cryptographic software and and the
source code for cryptographic software
and whether or not the source code that
you allow you to encrypt your words was
protected speech and there you kind of
two steps removed from speaking out in
the open
both because we're talking about being
able to encrypt speech so it's sort of
private speech but also because we're
talking about not just the speech itself
but we're talking about the technology
used and the source code for the
technology used to make that speech
confidential ultimately we did get a
court to say that that source code was
protected by the First Amendment and
that because it fed into this tradition
of being able to speak anonymously in
the United States so any impulse whether
it's in this country or in Britain and
it would be incredibly damaging to our
traditions of free expression question
in the back
it's a it's a general question but the
question essentially what what would a a
regulated a Content regulated internet
look like work for the consumer you want
to go first
never been to China actually if you look
around the world that you'll find a
whole variety of different ways of
exerting control some more successful
than others or content online in this
country we're just so used to to freedom
we're so used to a free internet it's
like breathing the air for us so that we
really don't think about what it would
be like if somebody restricted it and
and unfortunately you still have
examples where people will try to and
that's why guys like me have a job but
you know in other countries there are
various mechanisms used in in China they
have the Great Firewall of course where
they tried to limit access by their
citizens to all kinds of information try
and go on and the Chinese equivalent of
Google and search the term Tiananmen
Square for example Saudi Arabia uses
much the same kind of technology where
they basically censor everything coming
into the country others have more
draconian ways of applying content
regulations so that you know if you post
something that is considered to be
insulting to the sovereign you know you
can be prosecuted for that was involved
in a case involving Yahoo actually this
was the u.s. service but Yahoo France
was complying with their
basically hate speech laws and and
anti-nazi memorabilia regulations
because in Europe there there's a very
strong tradition now if the post-world
War two
of not permitting anything that is in
any way considered to be apologetic for
the Nazi regime or anything like that
and so even posting a copy of mine Kampf
online can be considered a violation of
that law but Yahoo in the United States
through its auction site had
availability people were marketing you
know third parties again copies of
various kinds of World War two and Nazi
memorabilia and so a suit was brought in
Paris against Yahoo in the United States
because it could be or at least brought
in France
concerning the US version of Yahoo
because it could be accessed over there
and there was a judgment issued in
France saying that Yahoo had to pay a
fine of I forget how much but it kept
adding up day after day that they were
still in violation now ultimately that
couldn't be collected and and the courts
in this country ruled that because they
wouldn't be able to come here and
enforce it because of the First
Amendment that you couldn't file a case
in this country to block a collection
that wasn't going to happen but in
France you know you you can't have
access to that material or take any of
the sort of content concerns that any
other government might want to express
whether it's anti hate speech or whether
it's Sharia law or whether it's you know
not saying anything bad about the
Vatican in Italy those those regulations
can be enforced there but not here you
asked what a dystopian vision of an
internet would be and I think Bob
mentioned you can't insult the Sultan
and that is very scary and I would just
add that the Sultan can be you know the
powers that be and I would only thing
and first of all it's just a privilege
cuz you know Bob is just a wealth of
information and it's been on the front
lines its first
and fight for so long that the thing
that we're at the tenth anniversary of
the Iraq war and the reason we were in
Iraq was because yes the government put
out lies but the media consolidated ran
with those lies and so there is a
concern that when power gets
consolidated and the information is
distributed through a few that we end up
with policies that are very damaging and
so I do think that a network neutrality
and I you but but it ties up here that
is regulated such that it's not a few
that can reach the homes the cars the
living rooms of this country but it is a
diverse source allows for multiplicity
of voices so I would be concerned my
dystopia would be an internet that is
the government's taking our information
and capturing it and the big companies
are charging much higher to be able to
reach at significant speeds and thereby
they get to reach the people of this
country just like they do on television
and I think that's very dangerous for as
we see at the 10th anniversary of the
Iraq war and how much treasure and lives
have been lost because we had a media
that did not ask the tough questions
independent media did independent media
did but independent media doesn't have
the reach there on the public access
channels but they don't have the access
to the cars and living rooms throughout
this country and so my dystopian version
would be one that mimics the current the
current set of media that we have with
the and that my utopian version would be
one that there's more space for
independent media for differing voices
and different perspectives that more
space for that and I think if that was
the case I think we'd have very
different domestic and foreign policies
in this country actually just just to
pick up on that because I think we start
at the same place when you're talking
about the 10th anniversary of the Iraq
war I think there's no question but that
the institutional media
fell down on the job in questioning and
being skeptical about justifications for
the war and for that reason the American
people for whatever reason whether it's
by the media or their own inclinations
also were insufficiently skeptical about
the justifications for that war now that
being said there were some major
newspapers the Cox chain for example
that did some some really good work
there are others that did as well there
were other independent voices and this
was in the Internet age when this
happened so it wasn't that people didn't
have access to sources of information
but for whatever cultural reason we as a
nation didn't ask the questions and we
ended up with some fairly disastrous
policies as a result but that being said
I don't know that that leads to the
policy conclusions that you reach and
again to draw on history we've kind of
seen this happen in the past it's
interesting that people talk about the
heyday of FCC regulation is when you
have all of this great Public Interest
regulation you have a Fairness Doctrine
you have regulations strict regulations
of ownership you have limited licensing
periods and that's the great period in
which we're promoting the public
interest and when the FCC stood for
something we were there some people say
but of course that was a time in which
we had three broadcast networks we had
nightly news that lasted for a half hour
we had a complete inability of
individual citizens to communicate and
that was because of basically a
regulatory structure that more or less
created and enforced that system of
limited access if you go back to the
early days of radio the early 20s for
example before the radio Act was passed
in 1927 you saw a period of
experimentation and a period of optimism
that was very much like the internet
period that we saw in the 1990s when
people were discovering the World Wide
Web
you had people tinkering in their
garages and people creating crystal sets
and people going on the air overnight
which did lead to interference and and
you had people developing solutions to
that for example developing better radio
receivers for one thing instead of
crystal says where he had to have a
safecrackers touch to get
any kind of radios radio signal and you
also saw some courts beginning to
develop systems of property rights for
people who had homesteaded different
frequencies but nonetheless Congress
stepped in in 1927 and put a stop to at
least the the legal developments in that
area and created a system that
essentially enforced the notion of
having essentially three major providers
and developed the system of controls
that were I think unprecedented in the
world of mass disseminated press at
least unprecedented since you know
England in in the 17 16th and 17th
century the interesting thing about that
the very first act of the federal radio
Commission in 1928 was to throw off the
air hundreds of radio experimenters
people who'd been out there sort of
creating the medium and instead enforced
strictly just who the licensed
broadcasters were going to be and as a
result we grew up with a limited number
of radio networks and then a limited
number of broadcast networks promising
efforts to have upstarts come and
challenge that structure fell by the
wayside largely because they could rely
on federal regulations to prevent them
from getting involved it wasn't until
the 1980s that Fox came along and you
know for whatever you feel about that
network or Fox News or anything else the
history is that there had been three
networks throughout the past it looked
like that was going to be the the fate
going forward and it was only because
you had an upstart challenging the
federal regulations that existed at the
time that you were able to create than a
fourth Network and then of course cable
came along well cable was already in
development but cable networks were
coming along as well creating much more
choice and diversity largely because
those networks were free of the kinds of
universal content regulations that
existed for broadcasting so even where
you can start by diagnosing a given
problem and thinking that the solution
to that is that we need someone to go in
and lay down
our history is that when someone does
you have almost exactly the opposite
result of what you would hope would come
about if I can follow what that that
that in some cases is the result of
often a maturing industry working with
government in some cases doing exactly
what they what they can do to create
barriers to entry from upstarts is there
a concern and and the government can in
to do this this is just what TV did this
with movies kind of intimidating an
industry into adopting some sort of
quote-unquote voluntary standards I'm
thinking of the movie rating systems
which was developed by Jack Valenti who
was a Johnson administration a part of
the Johnson administration everybody
went along with it the government the
the print the studio's the exhibitors
because they wanted at the movies to be
a a place where families could go to a
friendly place but at some say that it
has really inhibited independent
filmmakers could there be a point where
the government approaches or begins to
pressure Google which owns YouTube you
know let's let's have some kind of
standard here we won't impose it but we
will strongly suggest you create it is
this is this pattern likely to repeat
itself or is it just to endemic right
now with with YouTube and other video
sources that you really can't can't get
that level of granularity or ratings or
or standards and practices into into the
internet especially entertainment I look
forward to hearing Bob starts I would
say that's already happened at the back
end of the sites that you have kind of
coercion where where these companies
basically have to go along to give up
their information of their customers so
maybe at the front end I'm not so sure
but the back end of the site and all the
information is being collected you know
I don't think the courts have clear I
think they there was an early the course
of clearly said this is you can't
transmit isn't
they've been working closely to do just
that well just to start with the issue
of what kind of information companies
are giving over the issue isn't whether
or not the companies can or should give
information under the right
circumstances the issue has always been
what process is required for that just
as you know the government can search
your home if they have a search warrant
they can wiretap your phone if they have
a search warrant it is the process that
protects our constitutional liberties
and when you're dealing with third-party
intermediaries the companies that
provide those services then the question
is what kind of process is required
since 1967 a key Supreme Court decision
in that time it did require a search
warrant to have a wiretap law was then
codified in 1968 and 1986 that applied
to that as well
I would think after you know after 9/11
when the Patriot Act was passed cobbled
together
oddly enough from proposals I had
testified against during the Clinton
administration the Patriot Act loosened
those standards and made it more
possible for information to be shared
and so again we get back to the question
and sistas the same debate over what
kind of process is required before
telecommunications companies and network
managers are required to share that
information because short of that kind
of requirement they're not in the
business for giving up your personal
information but the question that you
started with which goes to government
and private companies collaborating I
would take issue with the example of the
movie rating system in part because MPAA
is a client and but but and I'm just
saying that in the name so for full
disclosure purposes but also because you
have to consider the alternative if you
go back to the early days of film and
the Hays office that was adopted by the
film production code that was a much
heavier type of censorship than
existed you had all of these pre-code
Hollywood films that are classics that
nobody had really heard about since
because things clamped down and there it
was sort of very strongly influenced by
government and it was it was a time
before courts even recognized First
Amendment protections for films and so
the industry stepped up to sort of
forestall government action and I think
all would acknowledge that it went way
too far but things began to change in
the 1960s and not only had courts begun
to strike down these various local state
censorship laws but Hollywood was also
trying to change with the changing legal
climate and also the cultural changes
that were happening in the 60s and so it
was then that the MPAA rating system the
production that you mentioned Jack
Valenti was instrumental in helping to
create did create a system so that
basically it's so that people can be
informed going into a film what they
might be likely to expect is it perfect
well no rating system is perfect but as
a private editorial judgment for what
kind of film to expect it's not a bad
guideline they routinely get about 80 to
85 percent consumer approval rate
ratings for whether or not people think
that the ratings are useful the question
of whether or not ratings can be used by
government is something very different
though any time you involve government
in either implementing these or
enforcing ratings decisions then
disasters occur and as a matter of fact
a lot of local governments when the
rating system was devised in the 60s
began to think this is such a fine idea
we should make it compulsory
matter of fact there was one case
involving a sheriff in North Carolina
that thought the rating system was such
a dandy idea that he was going to
prohibit any drive-in theater in his
jurisdiction from showing anything above
AG rating so fortunately the courts have
always made short work of those kinds of
ratings obviously taking care let's
drive through to
they have exactly they have they have
always been struck down and I think
anytime you combine sort of an official
improviser with a private editorial
system a rating system then you're going
to have a constitutional issue we we are
about out of time I want to thank our
guests Robert Korn Revere First
Amendment attorney Pete Tucker of the
fight back dot-org and Pete's may not
agree with everybody in this room but if
you visit his website you can see what's
being done with real street-level
journalism on the website and it is a
great example of how the Internet can be
used to do reporting that is not
reported in the mainstream media so
thanks for your attendance thank for you
online thank you to our guests thank you